occidente está a un paso de reforzar el
armamento que le envía a Ucrania el
viernes se reunirán en la base aérea de
Alemania Rammstein los líderes de la
otan y de 50 países más para discutir
sus acciones frente a la guerra y la
presión está sobre Alemania el país se
ha negado a enviar sus tanques leopardos
y tampoco permite que los aliados de
Ucrania usen su territorio para ello
no hay una decisión del Gobierno Federal
de entregar los tanques de batalla y
como la decisión no se ha tomado no
estamos pensando mucho más sobre esta
cuestión Tan pronto como se toman las
decisiones siempre hemos sido muy
rápidos en implementarlas
el canciller Alemán intentó liberar
presión desde davos en el foro económico
mundial anunció el cambio de ministro de
defensa del país y este miércoles
prometió enviar el sistema de misiles
pero nada de tanques pesados Berlín teme
actuar solo y que Rusia tome represalias
Aunque su panorama está cambiando
Polonia y Finlandia quieren enviarle a
Ucrania los leopard y Reino Unido subió
la presión al ser el primer país
occidental en prometer blindados 14
tanques Challenger equiparables al
leopard
no estamos solo Esta es una coalición
internacional conjunta y sé que el
cuerpo político alemán está preocupado
no quieren hacerlo solos bueno no están
solos y creo que la conferencia en
Rammstein lo demostrará
la otan se suma y dice que es necesario
aumentar significativamente la ayuda a
Ucrania para forzar una paz negociada y
según de New York Times Estados Unidos
trasladará más de 300.000 proyectiles de
artillería desde Israel donde las
almacena por eso el viernes en Rammstein
kiev podría salir fortalecido